man where to pay up my bets how'd it go
cousin I'm proud of you after the 28 to
20 the next time we do this though this
is twice now when you've put me in this
box where if the Vikings win a game I
think they're gonna lose you make me
wear the Kirk Cousins Jersey there has
to be something that happens to you
yourself I didn't I mean it's fine I
don't know what else I'm not taking the
challenge unless you put something cause
it's Kirk because it's cousin you hear
what he just said
oh of course here come what am I gonna
say qualifying see what am I gonna say
the team won well you know what but when
he says that yes the point is don't
blame me when we lose it's not me Lou
it's a team game those effort this is
his effort three weeks early to deflect
the blame when they lose in Seattle oh
my god you're the worst Viking realist I
wanted to be right last night I thought
the Cowboys were gonna win the game I
don't understand it and DeMarcus
Lawrence does his team no favors he
played well yeah it was all over the
place last night
but don't say before the game and this
was like Thursday or Friday last week
we're gonna take the wheels out of the
Vikings offense out of the running game
because the passing game can't be tits
look they didn't do either didn't do
either kick Dalvin cook had 97 yards
Alexander Madison added some decent
yardage as well there was a drive in the
third quarter where the vikings ran the
ball ten straight times broke the spirit
and the will of the Cowboys defense so I
look I got I give the whole Vikings team
credit and it is one of those games
where it could have been a blowout but
it also could have gone the other way
Vikings up 14 nothing make Gotha mated
21 nothing they didn't but they had they
hung in there and once they fell behind
they Unleashed that drive was with ten
straight runs and and they pulled it off
and they held on at the end the D for
the passing defense for the Vikings was
horrible yeah I think you have multiple
receivers with over 100 yards pass
defense is not good right but the good
thing about that and you know I do think
that Mike Zimmer
picked the poison there as far as okay
if I'm gonna get beat by the Cowboys and
I have to choose whether I want Zach
Prescott to throw for 350 or over 350
something yards or Zeke Elliot run for
130 to 150 yards he
take the doc Prescott throwing the ball
one because he got the time of
possession win yesterday yeah the
Cowboys beat teams with running the ball
controlling the clock sometimes and it's
hard for your offensive getting rhythm
so he kind of did what the Cowboys do to
them and they controlled the clock and
you guys ran the football you have the
Cowboys I'm sure I mean as you said the
Marcus Lawrence they wanted to stop the
run game and they did a solid job
I mean Dalvin cook didn't go off but
still it's all the other things they do
off the run game that's so special that
this year it's not complicated it's the
run it's the bootlegs it's the fake the
bootleg screen right and that's where
Dobbin cook was really awesome last
night too was in the screen game and
he's proven you know him and Christian
McCaffrey are in a neck-and-neck race
for who's the best running back in
football with the score 28 24 late in
the fourth quarter the Vikings head the
ball back and it wasn't late when they
got the ball back they made it late
because they chewed up a lot of time off
the clock the drive petered out in
Cowboys territory
the Vikings punted the Cowboys were
pinned at their 5-yard line they moved
the ball effectively officially and it's
almost like the Vikings defense wasn't
even on the field they were so worried
about getting beat deep they were giving
up and I think Kris call it the nonstop
rout last night where you fake like
you're going deep yeah you slam on the
brakes there's nobody there because
they're so worried about being burned
over the top right they give you that
ten yards and it was just chunk chunk
chunk it was but two-minute warning the
Cowboys are inside the Vikings 20 first
and 10 at the 19 deck profile tomorrow
Cooper for 8 yards that's typical of
what they were doing on the drive but
then yeah they resort to the running
game there you go Ezekiel the kids
bottled up on second down yeah he gets
really jammed in the backfield on third
down and then fourth down Erik Kendricks
one has been playing great linebacker
this year especially in past coverage
breaks it up that's not the game by any
stretch because the Vikings ultimately
had to punt the Cowboys ended up having
some chances to throw the ball into the
end zone
tavon Austin and look they told him did
you see that do not really do not return
easily he'd go gotten the ball into
Vikings territory but
either way the Vikings had to sweat it
out at the end they did have that great
stop on the drive that felt like the
Cowboys we're gonna go up 31 28 and then
the Vikings gonna have to try to do some
kind of a last-gasp thing but a lot of
criticism the Cowboys for how they they
handled those two don't run the ball in
that spot when the the the passing game
has carried you down the field and
position Y in the water trying to pop it
through with the zqi lead the Vikings
were all over they were I mean the Mike
Zimmer was not gonna be outnumbered by
the run game all night so he always had
an extra guy in there for as far as if
there was five blockers he had six
defenders in there you know if it was
six blockers he had seven he was not
gonna let that happen which left him
vulnerable to the outside like you're
saying but at the same time when those
moments came around like they're at the
end of the game you know you stop the
run you know okay yeah we're gonna stop
the run we're gonna make them throw the
ball and you know on a fourth down
because we're gonna like hopefully get
the ball back even if they do score they
were not gonna let the run game beat
them and I think there's nothing wrong
with that now yeah they're susceptible
to that stuff outside
Xavier Rhodes is not good this year you
know Mike Hughes is still coming their
other corner who made his start last
night for Trey Wayne's he's coming back
from an ACL injury he's like what just a
year out from that so he's not a hundred
percent and Amari Cooper's awesome so
it's tough to stop that Dallas it's not
afraid to play that one-on-one ball but
again the Vikings that was a big win for
their football team that's gonna give
your your squad a lot of confidence
going here going okay we can go on the
road we could win these type of football
games and Dalvin cook the defense Kirk
Cousins Mike Zimmer it was it was a
great job by all of them to get the win
it's not just on the road it's on the
road it's at night it's everything
together it's the circumstances of the
game and they have some games coming up
that are gonna have similar
circumstances three weeks from tonight
at Seattle they'll be coming out of
there by week so they have extra time to
get ready for it but at Seattle is never
easy especially at night there's a night
game scheduled for LA against the
Chargers week 15 that could be flexed
out which would be good news for the
Vikings week 16 Monday night game
against the Packers who are still one
game ahead of the Vikings in the NFC
North so that is not going to be an easy
run for the Vikings and they're going to
have to continue to build on what they
did last night if they want to be
standing when the playoffs roll around
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports